we need to figure out the least common
multiple of 30 and 25 so let's get our
little scratch pad out here and we care
about 30
and we care about 25. and i'm going to
do this using the prime factorization
method which i just like more
so 30 let's find the prime factorization
of both of these numbers so 30 it's
divisible by 2. it's 2 times 15.
15 is 3 times 5 and now we've expressed
30 as the product of only prime numbers
2 times 3
times 5. now let's do the same thing for
25. 25 is well that's just 5
times 5. so let me write that down 25 is
equal to 5 times 5.
now to find the least common multiple
let me write this down the least common
multiple of
of 30
30
and 25 is going to have a number whose
prime factorization
is a superset of both of these or has
all of these numbers in them as many
times as we have in any one of these so
it's least common multiple well it has
to be divisible by 30. so it's going to
need a 2
times a 3
times a 5. this is what makes it
divisible by
30 but it needs to also be divisible by
25. in order to be divisible by 25 you
need to have two fives in your prime
factorization right now our prime
factorization only has one five so let's
throw so we have one five right over
here we need another five so let's throw
another five right over here so now this
thing clearly has a 25 in it it's
clearly divisible by 25 and this is the
least common multiple i could have had
if we just wanted a common multiple we
could have thrown more we could have
thrown more factors here and it would
have definitely been divisible by 30 or
25 but it has the bare minimum of prime
factors necessary to be divisible by 30
and 25. if i got rid of any one of these
i wouldn't be divisible by both anymore
if i got rid of this 2 i wouldn't be
divisible by 30 anymore if i got rid of
one of the fives i wouldn't be divisible
by 25 anymore so let's just multiply it
out this is essentially the prime
factorization of our least common
multiple and this is equal to
2 times 3 is 6 6 times five is thirty
thirty times five is equal to
one hundred and fifty and of course we
can check our answer
one hundred and fifty
check it and we got it right